it's time to answer a fan question
something we do every week
and since this is our 100th show
we thought we'd do something special hey
jesse hey mike my name is josh and i am
calling from saskatoon saskatchewan
canada i just want to say i love the
podcast and i look forward to it every
week
i have a question about a bit that
was on late night with conan o'brien and
it really kind of took on a life of its
own inspired website uh maybe a fall
live stream as well
that is the horny manatee.com sketch
if memory served me correctly i think
conan had mentioned something about
visiting hornymanatee.com
and he found out after that if somebody
in a position of power mentions a
website name
nbc require them to actually buy it and
kind of make it a thing
so that led to quite a
long running
uh
sketch with this recurring theme of the
horny manatee and i'm just wondering is
it true that uh you guys actually had to
buy the domain and it kind of you know
morphed into what i think to be uh one
of conan's funniest bits i'd be
interested to hear a little bit more
thanks again guys take care thanks josh
thank you josh wow that's a great
question that's a very specific question
i know
and we have not addressed that before
certainly not
i know i've we've been waiting never
come up but yeah so we do have to buy
the domains if we mention a website on
the show in any capacity right if it's
in a comedy sketch we have to make sure
that that website doesn't already exist
right and then purchase it if it doesn't
and the reason for that is let's say
someone else buys the site and puts
stuff up there that could be offensive
etc then we'd be liable for any
negative yeah and we wouldn't get any of
the profits either yeah exactly right of
course i never thought which would be
unfair oh yeah but it occurred to us
while we were thinking about this
question that there the person who
managed the websites and finding making
sure that the urls were available on our
show
was actually jordan schlansky is that
right jordan that is right that's
correct you're here with us yeah hi
jordan i'm here yes so we thought we
would go to the horse's mouth
to get an answer on this please welcome
mr jordan schlansky hello jordan hi
thank you guys for having me you've just
sent us a photo oh this is a photo of
you with the horny manatee yeah as josh
mentioned uh we had mentioned the url
horny manatee in a uh comedy sketch and
this was december of 2006. oh wow look
at those sideburns uh that picture is me
and dan gore of course former writer on
late night with glenn devine who's gone
on to do fantastic things yes have you
had him on the show yes we've had dan on
the show in season one i believe okay
yeah
checking up on us so in order to say the
website on the air as mike mentioned the
network had a policy that we purchased
it to ensure that there would be no
questionable content and we had done
that a few times before with other
websites and then one of the writers uh
which i believe was dan had the great
idea that hey listen if we own this site
anyway let's make a comedy bit out of it
and uh we made it into a functioning
website we would do photo shoots and
feature kind of erotic manatee themed
artwork on the website and the picture i
just sent is a behind the scenes photo
of dan and myself
positioning the manatee for one of the
aforementioned erotic themed photo
shoots
what position do you think that was
going to be
it's just sort of spread eagle right now
based on the limitations of the
articulation of the particular costume i
don't know that there was that much we
could do with it unfortunately i i
actually looked up the website it you
know for a while we had it functional
and then later on nbc just had it direct
to their own home page and now the
website goes nowhere but i looked and
not only does nbc still own it but they
renewed it as recently as last year oh
interesting
it may be their general policy to never
let the urls expire or maybe there's
some future maybe they hope we're gonna
come back
meanwhile that's where a third of their
income comes from right yeah
yes it was originally a comedy bit i i
couldn't quite remember the details but
there's a big article about it in the
new york times at the time we used to do
bad ncaa mascots and one of them was
that dan came up with it was supposed to
be a manatee on a webcam and he was
trying to do a lascivious dance and mark
pender our band trumpeter we cut to him
watching this on his laptop and then
conan just did an ad-lib panders on
horny manatee.com and then because he
ad-libbed that after the show jordan i
do you remember this i'm imagining
that's when you would have kicked into
action yeah that one was surprisingly
available uh
in this day and age there are very few
combinations of words that haven't been
purchased yet but back in sweet innocent
2006 yeah there was a lot more
availability and no one had thought to
purchase horny manatee and that's right
dan had a great idea to like let's make
it a real site right and yeah and then
do comedy about it and we invited fans
as you said to start sending in their
own horny manatee fan art so it's one of
the early interviews it's also a
dangerous thing to do now probably
website bits yes well one of the
interesting um feel good stories related
to this situation was that yeah we were
i believe selling shirts i've also sent
you a photo of one of the logos that we
had on the shirt okay and all of the
proceeds that we made went to um a
legitimate manatee foundation because
they were and maybe inseminating
manatees uh yes a threatened species and
uh we sent it i forgot the name of the
foundation is based in florida and we
were in regular contact with them making
sure they got the proper proceeds and
they loved what we were doing and uh i
mean if they loved it to me that's a
blessing that the manatee community in
general was on
board don't know if they love the
content as much as the check that was
getting sent to them but i remember
conan quickly soon afterwards like i
don't like that bit i think he hated the
costume
because it was so
it was just it doesn't even really look
like a vanity it looks like it was
adapted from something else like they
took a yeah the trunk off an elephant or
something yes i've seen
so few actual manatees in my life that
my the image i have in my head of a
manatee is that costume no that's
terrible yeah that's upsetting they all
have that big seam around their neck can
i say question what jordan what would
have happened if conan had said that
website and then you found out that it
belonged to somebody else well what
often happens is if that's the case the
standards department screens all of our
shows and after the show if they hear a
website like that they'll check in with
me and ask uh if we knew it was going to
happen and if so if we purchased the url
ideally we would tell them yes in cases
where we haven't um they usually ask us
to censor either the entire name of the
website or maybe just the dot com or dot
biz part of it um just to leave some
ambiguity there so they have plausible
deniability that they didn't actually
endorse a particular website that could
be problematic there was a lot of times
if a website's unavailable it doesn't
necessarily contain questionable content
but the threat is that in the future
when a show repeats we can't control
what would be on the website then the
only sure way is to own it there was one
example normally we kind of roll their
eyes when we get these notes um
if something is ad-libbed in the show
and we have to censor something we're
never happy about it yeah because it
almost makes it sound worse it makes it
sound worse censor it we don't want the
perception that we're a show that falls
under high amounts of censorship back on
the tbs show in 2014 we had the cast of
orange is the new black on and uh
laverne cox was one of the cast members
on the show and she had mentioned
um her twin brother and that he had a
website he was a musician she said and
she wanted to promote his website and we
didn't know about it in advance and um
normally if a celebrity asked to plug
one of their websites there's a lot more
leniency involved than if it's just an
unknown website you know we want to make
sure that we you know treat the talent
well and usually they're harmless sites
normally i'll check out a website in
advance in that case it was ad-libbed i
did not have the opportunity so after
the uh taping i immediately got an email
from the
standards department saying that we
needed to censor the website and again
in the interest of talent relations she
was only promoting her brother's musical
website i kind of went back to them and
pushed back a little bit and said that
we'd like to keep it
you know let's cut some slack and i got
an email back
which i've located and i'd like to read
it to you sure
after i said that we'd like to keep this
url dimension on air of laverne cox's
brother's website i was told there is a
pornographic image on the front page of
the site of three men being anally
penetrated by objects
those are musical instruments and that
was from the standards of practice this
is from standards and bracket
immediately uh to verify the accuracy of
the email i went to the website and in
fact well of course that was certainly
the case
i can't say i disagree with the logic of
this policy as much as we disliked it at
times it's interesting because i mean
all of this honestly i feel a little bit
bad because we've sort of dispelled here
the myth that you don't do anything for
the show i'm i'm sort of i'm upset to
know that you occasionally did things
you would have preferred it if i did not
do things i would yes right
that's part of your mythology do you
feel some level of sorrow that my image
was unnecessarily tarnished by the the
myth that i didn't do anything i still
don't know if we've shown you have
actual duties all i've heard is you were
looking at three men being anally
penetrated
i don't know if that's work if so and
you are holding up that's a good point
the flap of a costume how many hours per
year would you say you spent researching
pornographic websites for work well if i
were to aggregate all of the requests
and the time that i spent looking at
them then the percentage of those that
were pornographic i'd say uh under 10
minutes per annum because that's what we
say in latin
yeah what a great use of latin